second game weekend of gifts Air Force
got late in the game fourth quarter
God dropped back he threw the ball to a
receiver coming down my sideline me and
I we went head off as soon as I hit the
guy focuses every breath of my body left
people think commitment is saying yes
I'll do it on the days when it felt good
but I've been committed to everything
that I ever started in my life and I
never stopped it in a football game in
2006 he made a tackle that completely
changed the course of his life he
suffered a life-threatening injury that
paralyzed his right arm it turned him
into a motivational speaker that
encourages people to embrace the
challenges of life he's inky johnson and
here's my take on his top ten rules
success rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'm super curious to figure
out which one you guys like the best
also as you're watching the clips if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
when you write something down it's much
more likely to stick with you to enjoy
[Music]
you know why people quit people don't
have pride in what they do you know what
people stop their selfish and it's just
about this when you have a bigger
purpose - why you're doing what you're
doing and you want to honor the
sacrifices that others have made for you
it's nothing for you to keep going when
you in at first if every decision and
choice you make is just about you
at a certain point you're going to hit
something that's a lot tougher than you
it's going to make you quit because you
don't have a driving force for why you
do what you do but when I got up to the
University of Tennessee it was simple
and was simple for me to give everything
I had my freshman year I played special
teams myself for season I broke the
starting lineup had a really strong
sophomore season that someone hadn't
into my junior year I still remember the
day where I was sitting in our film room
I was watching film on the California
bears my defensive backs coach Larry
Slade came in the room he said inky I
got some good news for you
I dropped the click I said what is it he
said man your projected top 30 draft
picks up he said all you have to do is
play the next 10 football games your
automatic multi-millionaire I went out
of the room I called my mother my
grandmother on the three-way I said
after this season there will be no more
struggle I said we would never miss
another man so we would never experience
another Christmas when we had to stand
on the side of the curve and just be
free now hung get up first football game
I went out playing weight got an
interception check count our second game
we ran against Air Force got late in the
game fourth quarter God dropped back he
threw the ball to a receiver coming down
my sideline me and the guy we went
head-on as soon as I hit the guy felt as
if every breath of my body left
body went completely left fell to the
ground I blacked out never happened
my eyes open I'll never forget my
teammates ran over this ain't get up
let's go cuz I can't
I can't move so what do you mean you
can't move y'all lockdown corner man we
need you let's go but I know man that
this time I can't move I filled my head
up please God see God there's surely
nothing that happen in this moment
that's an auction my life it got me to
the hospital took me back they ran
cat-scans they brought me back into my
room and all in a 15-second timeframe
the doctor came running in from the
opposite side he said get in there we
gotta rush this guy back to emergency
surgery he's about to die I said what he
said son you have busted up subclavian
artery in your chest you're bleeding
internally we have to rush you back take
the main vein out of your left leg
plugged into your chest in order to save
your life
when I open my eyes from recovery the
same doctors over me said son has some
good news and some bad news for you I
said you got some bad news for after
telling us about the dime still alive
how bad can it get I'm still here he
said the good news is we saved your life
I said thank you sir he said the bad
news is ain't we have nerve damage in
your right shoulder I said okay cool he
said my son is a strong possibility that
you probably could never play the game
of football again in your life I said no
way I said no disrespect to you doc but
I've been working for this ever since I
was seven years old I said no disrespect
to you doc but you wasn't in the park
with me and my mother now was seven
years old he was sending that gear we
got he got done working at Wendy's
no disrespect you doctor you didn't come
up and had to back when 114 people
sleeping on the floor no disrespect to
you doc but you can miss those meals and
stay focused and never made an excuse I
never cheated I never cheated like luck
constants still until his date won't let
me like I can't gene I can't look myself
in the mirror and say if you did a good
job knowing that I kid I can't cheat one
of the greatest pieces of advice that my
mother gave me was says so whenever you
start you make sure you finish and the
problem with the world today people get
involved with things and if they don't
like a certain person if they don't like
the process if they're not what they
thought it was they quit and what they
don't understand about quitting wouldn't
becomes a habit that doesn't disinfect
you later on in life when you get a wife
and you get some kids when you get a
family it's going to come back to haunt
you and then when one day affects this
that is why I tell you the process is
more important than the product it's not
even about the outcome for me it's about
can you say Friday what you do as an
individual every night when you look in
the mirror knowing that you gave
everything you add to it and we have to
get to the front where we're willing to
impose our will on certain things impose
your will on it my life totally changed
and they gave me an opportunity to stop
and most people when you give them an
opportunity to stop while they're
chasing something they take advantage of
it because they feel as if man why does
this have to happen to me I felt as if
why not me
this is the perfect opportunity to use
this to be a blessing to somebody else
and you know what it's not even about me
to be truthful it's not even about me
now it's about repairing the people that
invested in me and saw something in me
when I consider myself at a certain
point in life it can't just be about you
in the moment that we understand that
and every day we wake up and understand
that life is the blessing and life is a
gift and if you were to check out the
date how would you want to be remembered
it's bigger than you into the hole
if the guy was going to hit and he
wanted and we couldn't get the guy on
water guy comes in arrow in the water we
can put a warning hostage and we can use
that bucket to that guy working question
that got like in some sense the bucket
was you need to play eyes and so
watching with images locket I believe
you get everything you got and
everything your part but give it
everything you got
go ahead hope that says the hard work
the hardness is the ring to be anonymous
to give up the ornament is not on it is
to get it until you give everything you
got - everything you're involved in the
only way able to live a whole life is
ever you get me Devon
and so at the end of every day our page
should be a theme in the next days I
love it
should we so only way to go back to the
store is there free every hour you never
deflected a source of the source of God
without much cool and give me present is
my conspiracy and especially until when
I empty my everything I know the nesting
when I wake up
we'll be back cool by the way I am too a
pocket is if I can see my book and get
everything I got and if you'd like
audience laughs it was rising up into
the bucket and get everything I've got
five three hydrogens of a book and give
everything I got
it is ours you like that is the way down
in love but the thing has understand is
less is more like you have to if you
pocket of the thing I can guarantee
about just in your bucket your babies
like if you made Richard Richard and you
have a person you both in here it
happens no men who have this joy who has
a piece that compose human will they
live I did everything I did
it wasn't about surfing was about or put
our freedom I was about me to combine
what I do and the person that I am and
isn't everything I've got everything
uninvolved can I be honest with you they
come in six times number left 140 left
side of my leg one time for white side
of the Nexus slicing my white [ __ ] put
out my backpack bottom of my heart fit
to the bottom of my hands 350 staples in
my body they manage me from a neck to my
knee it's not look here and I got to be
honest with you is day to wear if I
could lay there I would have made it but
my spirit so that's not really walk
mum and Alan that's not only war I got a
little about you or I'm spider-man
I fight for my bowl I fight for my dream
I fight for the things that I've got
possessed and the thinking of a part of
and I dare you the things that you do
the things that you're a part of and the
things that you're connected to again
every single day is short and give
everything you've got you a day every
single day you wake up you understand
you represent something a lot greater
than yourself I feel you both with
fifteen dollars in it give everything
you've got to it go home to your family
go to your careers give everything
you've got to every aspect of your life
not David watch what happens that you've
been taught as a matter of fact like my
father or son tells me a couple ballsy
you
don't eat that
please oh we can't do you know you
really are and it's not
you
and you want to get using they don't
like that
like that
when you think about life everybody
wants to prize but nobody wants to
process everybody wants to championship
but nobody wants to day-to-day everybody
wants to win games but nobody wants to
put in the work that it takes to win
game and the Bible talks about in
Proverbs it says the labor is an
appetite works for him and his hunger
drives them more the labourers appetite
works for him and his hunger drives the
month and so my question to you all is
what's your appetite for winning because
if you have an appetite for winning your
hunger with drives me every day your
hunger will take you to the weight room
your hunger will take you pass through
to your hunger will take you past our
position your hunger will take you past
at versing your hunger will take you
fastest trouser tribulation your hunger
will take you to that full quarter when
it's four zeros when they cost us
anything that buckles you have given
everything you've had in that game since
a certain mindset man will you attack
this thing the game of football
it's not about skill that's what people
mr. bodeaux in this game is not about it
has nothing to do with skill
it has nothing to do with the 40 yards
as it has nothing to do it telling the
40 inch vertical what this game is about
it's about well that's it
it's not about skill this game is about
well and so the moment that you make up
in your mind the day that you make up in
your mind that you're going to play this
game for God to give everything you've
got to it you can't help but to give
everything you've got and that's the
moment that you realize the game has
nothing to do it still I've seen plenty
of Tennessee guys forward I've seen
plenty of Turtles the guys getting hit
in the mouth and they didn't wound I've
seen plenty to tell us the guys just
punched in the face if they go back to
the sidelines they send one side they
coaching they don't loan it no more they
make up excuse nothing plenty of towns
of guys they were in a 4248 benchpress
225 pounds when 31 came up they capped
their helmet to come out of the game
that has nothing to do it skill
see if your life doesn't have purpose in
life is like a pencil with the field
it has move everybody get up you don't
have any direction but when you get up
every day to have a post you have a
paralyzed right over the enemies then
you can't use that help any move that
they can use this old everyday waiting I
live my life and my life has purpose
I don't done in my life that's why some
of the decisions of the choices that I
have to make nobody understood because
it wasn't about anything else
those about worth that easily pull me
out arguments that are more so from
behind
Adelina less before them every day we've
got make it bigger than mr. job let how
you continue that's how you really
always s
he voiced opposition if you just going
to happen we just reach out and you do a
bring people freaked out but you love is
success for your products and your
politics professor you brought it down
you don't give anything nothing this you
don't get anything back you get an asset
if you like to the neck so that what you
get [ __ ] it what do I need free
[Music]
doctor walk by my baby city we'll get to
know each other well you've been at
hospital for the next 40 days I walked
out of hospital Thursday I was back in
class next week I was back at practice
and a financial firm actually next week
I had to learn how to write all over
here
but they learn how to walk and people
come with New York I think how did you
do it man doctor how did you do it how
did you make it out of hospital man
how did you do ask you to them right
it's cute it's cute to them right why
did you do it man and people don't
understand when I say the process saved
my life like they don't get it and when
I say the process that saved my life in
the process is more important in the
product what I'm trying to tell them was
when I was in the park for my mother
when I was seven years old she was
sitting in the Buick Regal that saved my
life when I was up every side of that
four o'clock in the morning running two
miles so five six two miles like oon
that say my when I never cheated that
saved my life when I didn't let my
teammates give up and quit that save my
life
because we're all me my hair was
paralyzed my spirit wasn't my heart
father my mentality was it I was the
same man that does that a paralyzed
vital man it couldn't stop me if they
wanted to I couldn't quit even if I
wanted to because of the spirit in the
soul that resides and he bounces the
game created that the process created
that and so understand when you're free
in sport it's a blessing because you're
in a control study it allows you to
build your character level bad practice
come back tomorrow have subtypes make it
up buddy
have a bad game Tomek Tamar next week
have a good game make it up buddy
it allows you to build your character
the one day we face real life opposition
we build your character and which really
made out of
but that's more poignantly product ESPN
call me they did a story on me this past
summer but they call me one day now
picked up the phone they said it's just
in De Anza the last time I checked a
leaky Johnson instead is this the same
guy that said if you could change what
happened to you you wouldn't I said
absolutely
they said it's our understanding the
game of football meant the world I said
at one point is this
they said it's our understanding that
your family which banking or your making
it to the NFL they can have a better way
of life okay yeah that's correct
instead we're coming to see you I said
alright cool come on except but we don't
want to see you in Atlanta we want to
see you in Neyland Stadium on a back
yard line with your life change the same
time of day the only thing that will be
present its Air Forces team all right
cool and so they take me to Nealon
Stadium they put me on the exact yard
line with my life change they send out
soldiers younger so why you wouldn't
stop your injury if you could if you
could be in the NFL right now making
millions of dollars tell you young
yourself why you wouldn't change that
situation if you could and I say the
reason I wouldn't change it believe it
or not has nothing to do with me that's
on a personal level you he thought I was
going to say because of the man that
I've become the perspective that I
requires my face doesn't fortified he
thought I was going to say something
like that I said no it has nothing to do
it has everything to do with the lives
that have been affected by the result of
the process and the thing that I
represent in the world what my spirit
represents when somebody see me they
think perseverance well my favorite
represents would somebody see me they
say don't quit but my spirit represents
when somebody see me they think that's a
quality individual racing what my
character represents in the world and
every single day we're putting something
out like that represent something when
people see that they think it's a
thought that comes to the must wear
instead gold sinner he came as I felt
inside already but he came to go sent I
felt the service I I felt different gold
standard I felt like that work with me
because I think in what I do the leather
business amends I'm the gold finger
because I don't compromise and every
single day I'm gonna give you my very
best you can bet your bottom dollar
every single day i'ma bring that gold
standard to life I'm not just bringing
aspect of life I'm bringing it every
single aspect of life I'm not going to
be one of these people in the world
that's a public success but they're
private so me they give everything and
gas is one aspect of life but the other
areas they lack all know I'm gonna give
every single thing I got every aspect of
my life because I represent something
when people see me they think something
whether that's Kairos s never giving up
never surrender
and the thing that we could never do is
forget what we represent because that's
how guys end up under bridge on a
cardboard box week they forget what they
represent when life hits them with
adversity my only charge for you never
forget what you represent I am NOT here
for me today I remember every one of you
all because I chose because I knew that
they will come one day I was heading for
hoop of children and Domino's we all
know what happened we grow like the
bottom adversity for for the opposition
the garden college-related let me guess
that we the only thing that's exactly a
juice notice is like in the pocket and
some people that were speaking like that
other person says decline you see I
heard something about you I can speak
for certain things
I know something about you without you I
don't see one good one is it is full and
do what I do even though I don't want
this is great you can do I just look you
go to power you can do it I know that
you want to come wherever it is that you
want to come but it's like that quote
you believe I want the water but you
can't open break you see I can tell you
all the right things I can say here is
their presentation but if you want that
we told you go live your life
remember still not so confirm it you
know you have engaged rather both
unemployed in the process because a lot
of people will surprise but not many
people support the process a lot of
people have the world when a few people
have the world to prepare to it the
process your soul to the prize the
process
what about the process coming into the
building they activate it everything you
got get bored easily individuals that
means the folks in order to make those
day passes you know release that goal we
move that whole division have dreams
exact without put basil really agree
with the before localized reason for
folks in order to listen that right does
he go free to the roles and success
across the ocean structures
we're putting files of Simeon people are
plenty of resources plenty of parking
spots to give on but this is if you were
to close to mother suddenly feel that
people prefer legal on the bubble star
would be safe
the only thing about life and definitely
be that gold would agree with whatever
it is that you aspire to do with the
life what do they not to tell you right
now away from everything sections but
the one thing I can never clean your
keyboard on the legal exists if you
don't give up if you don't stop if you
don't give it nothing will defeat you
nothing will conquer you
stop never give up never stop never
doubt is a movie
the golden book is always the mother
inside you that shortages anything that
right silhouette I have been working my
whole life and what I did understand by
being determined to chase something by
being committed to it and what
commitment is commitment and true to
what you said you were going to do long
after the mood that you have citizen has
left you see people saying commitment is
saying yes I'll do it on the days when
it felt good but I've been committed to
everything that I ever started in my
life and I never stopped and I never
quit it and so by being committed to
everything that I started I finished it
it built a strong type of spirit it
built a certain type of mentality it
built the certain type of individual and
so now I couldn't quit even if I wanted
to I couldn't lay in the bed even if I
wanted to I couldn't stop even if I
wanted to I had too much but equity in
my life and everything that I was doing
because I understood my existence wasn't
about me
I went from me to we a long time ago I
understood the process is more important
than the product it wasn't about the
outcome for me once I made it to the NFL
or not that was inconsequential in God's
plan for my life but I was going to fall
in love with that process because I
understood by falling in love with that
process it was going to turn me into a
machine
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Mark Clark alpha
pronounce that okay asked me to to the
famous entrepreneur that you are made of
profile next leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know what if in key
stage that has the biggest impact on you
what lesson you're going to take from
this video that you will immediately
apply to your life or to your business
leave it down in the comments I'm going
to join in the discussion finally I want
to give a quick shout out to Felipe
Thank You Felipe so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
making that awesome video talking about
it I'm glad it had an impact on you and
I really appreciate your support on this
book even talk about the importance of
living with purpose evan has a channel
on YouTube called Evan Carmichael and he
always said believe he said believe is
his one word so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
the other thing I was going to keep it
in you the guys kept seeing him in jail
trying to Canadian NFL prospect I'll try
to keep going here and I'll try to
diversity I do it and I just a negative
I want to put it on a game expert stuff
when you go with a guy just beat up the
first press you just reverse real good
to first and after this method I will
need emotion I'm tipping out that I can
tell you why you can't do the work I
don't even know upset when I bet you the
type of person that when there's
something that you like and then
something that's evenings when it's
something that how did you something
that pushes you outside you come to zone
you try to find a witness it'll rattle
discover cool I got new before you hit
the Delta challenge we will change if it
doesn't challenge you it will change
until the point when the light bulb goes
off and you say man I can be given
everything I've got Gehrig's animal part
of the brain has a two million euro
machine and it's asking you will travel
to automatically protect you and so when
you get a situation or environment
that's uncomfortable and waiting try to
protect you and so as rain was gone
you gotta kick it into gear that he had
never been to before environment man him
you know you don't work like that
let's go until you know you don't go off
like that like you're lying to yourself
and though the reason I think don't keep
that whatever you do the reason I'm
saying is because the method by
if you got a bowl of dream or aspiration
thought unless you really want a
conference and you will be all they're
nice and will sacrifice the designated
steak a minute you will set up for this
white oak slabs or the manifest and you
must give it everything you've got
it comes now for America and it doesn't
matter that's where did you want
Samantha I'm from like my hands I can
say okay I get the wasn't in the cards
for me
what's that but the thing I can't do is
they made this is the goal
this is the dream just ask questions
these are things that I want to do my
life and I'm sorry and I'm sure I
couldn't pull it and then it comes time
for that dream that goal or the
aspiration to manifest and it doesn't
turn out the way that I want it to turn
out
I say man why not get what I would
prefer no that important and you know
amazing things we got you might live in
the world every day they expect results
that they haven't even worked I got that
news for you man you've got your scope
Google Apps with Gmail app school
parents Google Apps for mental but the
one thing they will not give you what
you have a mark for 50 gram and no time
with Blair blossom Chet it throw how is
when I was sacrificing our dedication
Alice commitment people are rewarded in
public for what they practice in fight
period and a home time in life you gotta
live with the thought of what if I gave
everything I had just one is to think
about the mentality that you will
possess if you gave everything you had
to everything that you were part of even
if it didn't turn out the way that you
want to turn out